when I come home dr. Karen l'amour Ana
has had to send her child away from
Manila for fear she might have been
exposed to the corona virus while at
work she sterilizes when she arrives
home from the hospital
her husband assumes he won't catch the
virus if his wife does I think we've
already come to terms with you know I
think it's already exposed too
he's trying to do his part as well in
trying to rip by trying to work from
homes with the lockdown on the
Philippine capital as well as regions to
the north and south of Manila where
public transport is paralyzed it's
become even more difficult for people
with vital jobs to get to work great
distances to get to their houses
well local governments have stepped in
with mobile kitchens and bike share
schemes for instance national government
leaders say guidelines are changing as
new problems emerge there may be
missteps and misunderstandings confusion
and conjecture frustration and fear we
appeal for patience and calm as we and
the whole world face an unprecedented
crisis I'm in the middle of one of
Manila financial districts and on a
normal day right behind me there'd be a
lot of people crossing the street but it
is an empty district right now with only
workers from the basic and health
services sectors allowed in and out
where it is busy however is a country's
main International Airport in Manila or
confusion over flight restrictions has
tourists making a mad rush to leave as
well as some of the millions of
Filipinos who work overseas so they
don't lose their jobs
Barnaby lo al Jazeera Manila